[Music]
eight news now is your local election
headquarters and today a judge denied a
request for a whole new election
lawyers for the election integrity
project argued the law for
mail-in voting this past election does
allow for
or for rampant fraud however lawyers
appointed to 1400 people who say
they live in california but who voted
here in nevada
the judge didn't buy that saying there's
no proof we're going to throw out an
entire election
and have everybody run for office all
over again
simply because
somebody voted who had moved
i mean you i'm just really struggling
with why on an emergency basis we would
throw out an election
another lawsuit heard today and thrown
out involves this race republican
congressional candidate jim marchant
lost his race by more than 30 thousand
votes
now his lawyer argued clark county's
signature verification machine
may not have worked properly and that
the county sent ballots to tens of
thousands of addresses
where voters no longer live